hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in the first chapters of book 10 of his
confession saint augustine is going to
for the very first time lay his cards on
the table what is the point of engaging
in all of these confessions to begin
with all these stories about his life
all these sort of inquiries into
important topics having to do with
everything from the divine and moral law
to the human emotions and everything in
between
well he tells us near the end of
chapter 4
therefore to such as you command me to
serve human beings that is i will reveal
not what i have been but what i now am
and what i still am but neither do i
judge myself in this manner then let me
be heard and that's sort of a summary
god you're telling me
that i should not just have this
one-on-one with you sort of narrating
everything in the eyes and to the ears
and before the mind of of god trying to
figure myself out but
also to other human beings and this is
an important
aspect of what he's doing
and at several points he says well what
is the
benefit or the profit and these are ways
of translating in english a
question quo fructo right with what
fruit with what enjoyment with what
goodness that we can derive from this
fructus is also used at certain points
in this and he's asking both
about what is the profit
for me what is the profit for myself in
doing this
and what is the profit for
other people why should i write this
down it's not as if god you know
sent an angel and said you know write
this down so people can hear this he's
not claiming to be a prophet or anything
like that instead he's doing some very
interesting
moral and theologically inspired
philosophy now in chapter one
he gives us one of the reasons and he
says this tells us what benefit i'm
getting from this he says
um
behold you have loved truth since he who
does truth comes to the light now this
is a
biblical verse and we'll look at that in
just a moment but what does he say
immediately after that this i wish to do
in my heart
before you in
confession and in my writing before
many witnesses so the two things
confession to you god confession of
myself but also to or in the face of
other people these are all connected
with each other
doing the truth one comes to the light
this is a sort of promise that's being
made
coming to the light coming to the good
life coming to happiness coming to god
coming to that as a person who can
actually be in a proper relation with
god
by doing truth not just
saying the truth
but doing truth this is going to be a
very important idea not just for
augustine but for people that he
influences later on this notion that
truth is not just something theoretical
but also something done
in action
now
a little bit later as i mentioned he
says that
this is you know one of the
this is the prophet i may confess to you
i've already said
what this is but
there's also another theme that comes up
as well and it was already there in the
passage that we began with
there's a contrast that augustine is
making
between
knowing or
confessing
what he was
qualis furim what i was right
and he says that these confessions are
not
about what i was as if that's completely
gone that's completely over
instead they're about what i am and what
i still am he says at one point and he
brings this up
several different times in these first
four
chapters what's going on there
he's saying
that although he has indeed changed his
life
and by accepting divine grace made a
better person
of himself in certain ways
he still does remain the person that
he's remembering the kid who stole the
fruits you know the
one who dabbled with manichaeism and
astrology
for a while the person who put aside the
mother of his his son
in order to you know think about getting
married and all of that fell through
all these things that he brings up and
this is an important point as well
by confessing he can in fact
know what he is rather than just
allowing it to remain in the past
there's another thing that he says as
well that i think is really important
here and this is in
uh chapter 2 as well
he says that
when i'm you know when i confess i don't
do this
just with bodily words and sounds but
with words uttered by the soul and with
outcry of thought of which your ear has
knowledge when i am evil to confess to
you is nothing else but to be
displeased with myself so
to have the right affectivity the right
feelings towards one's own deficits
one's own
misdeeds one's failures and screw-ups
whether they're in the past or whether
they're still continuing on
in the present that's feeling or
thinking rightly about the good and the
bad in himself
what about the good stuff does the
confessions allow him to sort of rest on
his laurels so to speak he says
when i uh am
upright of life
nor else is it to confess to you but to
attribute this in no wise to myself
why why doesn't he want to take credit
for the good things
because he says listen the good stuff
that i have is attributable to god it
doesn't mean that i didn't have any
place in it you know if god gave me
grace and i did something with it that's
awesome but i didn't make my own grace i
didn't
form the goodness within myself you know
entirely
self-generated he says for you bless the
just man but first you justify him as
one who has been
ungodly so my confession is made in
silence before you god and yet not in
silence so his confession is
not just in these interior words
it's also in his
feelings his aff activity
what benefit is it to write this down
for others why not just sit in his
house and think these thoughts and then
you know
leave it
untalked about and
don't write a book that will
influence literature and theology and
philosophy and history throughout the
ages what benefit is it to others
augustine i mean there's a lot of things
you can say well it's you know a great
book to to read and to make other people
read and we can have great book clubs
and talk about it or i can even say
that's that's really not the point
that's not what this is about
so
he says first off
it can provide some hope to people right
readers will not despair and say i
cannot because they can look at
augustine
i often mentioned in my class that
augustine is a very relatable saint
because he sinned so much and it took
him decades to actually get himself
right with god and i think that makes
him you know a little bit more relatable
than some of these saints where you you
know we say butter wouldn't melt in
somebody's mouth they're so awesomely
good that you can't really say oh yeah i
can you know i've been in a situation
like that no augustine says listen if
i the miserable thing that i am can be
made good
so can you and so reading this
you know you can look at it and say oh
well there's there's hope so there's
hope of what he calls god's
mercy
that it extends right the other thing
that he says is people are curious about
me you know he's kind of a
a celebrity in ways right he was an
important person
over time
and he you know he says that um
here we go
um
i yeah
as to what i am now at this very time
when i make this confession many men
wish to know about this
both those who have known me and others
who have not known me they've heard
something
from me or about me but their ear is not
placed to my heart
where i am whatever i am so they want to
hear me confess what i am within myself
where they can extend neither their eye
nor ear nor mind this they desire is men
ready to believe otherwise how could
they know it and so he's saying you know
this isn't just
curiosity this isn't some period
interest this is wanting to know what's
the deal with this guy he clearly had a
big
change
what's what's going on how did this
happen what's his thought process well
that's what the confessions are going to
provide
the other thing that he says and this
kind of echoes
augustine himself feeling the right
sorts of things
is that the what he calls brethren his
uh you know brothers and sisters can
feel the right affects or feelings
in relation to augustine in relation to
his story what does this sort of thing
mean he says that
here we go
let it be that brotherly mind which when
it approves me
rejoices over me when it disproves
disapproves of me is saddened over me so
rejoicing and sadness right we see
augustine screwing up we're like oh that
that sucks right we and we're not just
like keeping him at a distance we feel
something about that we might even feel
that way about ourselves and looking at
our own failures when we see him doing
well we're like oh this is good i'm
happy to see that
he goes on and he says
for the reason that whether it approves
or disapproves it loves me
there's a relation of love that's
possible
through
this literature he says to such people i
will reveal myself may they sigh for my
good deeds may they sigh over my bad
deeds and all my goods are things that
you have established they are your gifts
my evils are my own misdeeds and your
judgments on me may they sigh for the
one and sigh over the other right so
aspiring to what the good things that
he's able to do
lamenting over the bad things that he
does and so he says such is the benefit
we go back to it right the the fructus
from my confessions
not of what i have been but what i am
that i may confess this not only before
you but also in the ears of believing
sons of men partakers of my joy
shares in my mortality my fellow
citizens and pilgrims with me those who
go before me and those who follow me
those who are companions on my journey
and so he says
this is very helpful perhaps
for my fellow christians or even those
being drawn into
christianity who can
use this work to
understand and to
have the right emotional
responses in relation to a compelling
story so that is what the confessions
are about this is the
project and we're getting it revealed to
us here
in the 10th book
you